[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem sonntag
kristin otto ist auch dabei für den
sport sehr gerne guten abend tag 11 des
krieges mit neuen angriffen vielen toten
und neuem scheitern auf die zweite
feuerpause wird gebrochen wieder muss
die evakuierung von zivilisten aus marie
jung voll verschoben werden
die russischen bomben vertreiben immer
mehr menschen aus ihrer heimat
mittlerweile sind es mehr als eineinhalb
millionen
in deutschland und vielen anderen
ländern wird gegen den krieg protestiert
auch in russland trotz des risikos mehr
als 3500 demonstranten wurden
festgenommen
der krieg ist ein irrsinn hört bitte auf
so der appell von papst franziskus heute
die diplomatischen bemühungen gehen auf
verschiedenen ebenen weiter so
telefonierten der türkische und der
französische präsident mit wladimir
putin auch israel versucht auf bitte der
ukraine zu vermitteln der krieg aber
geht weiter alexandra vacano und
christian volk
der krieg kennt kein wochenende an
diesem sonntag sind busse richtung mario
pohl unterwegs um die menschen aus der
eingekesselten stadt zu evakuieren
mario pohl die hafenstadt seit tagen
unter beschuss die menschen sollen über
einen humanitären korridor in drei
stunden entfernte sapori cia gebracht
werden eine sichere ausreise sei wieder
möglich heißt es am morgen im krieg
spricht aus der russischen armee
wir werden alles tun damit die menschen
die in eine von den ukrainischen
behörden und nationalisten vorbereitete
falle geraten sind das territorium
verlassen und überleben können
doch die evakuierung aus der hafenstadt
mit rund 440.000 einwohnern scheitert
wieder die menschen in der stadt ohne
strom ohne heizung die not ist groß
neben mario pohl ist auch kiew weiter im
fokus russische truppen die die
hauptstadt weiter umzingeln ganz in der
nähe in ihre pin reißt der strom der
flüchtende nicht ab
gestern haben sie tag und nacht
geschossen das krankenhaus getroffen die
universität das finanzamt sie schießen
jeden tag
diese aufnahmen sollen zeigen wie schwer
die angriffe auf ihre kleinstadt gewesen
sein müssen viele städte in der ukraine
sind bombardiert und schwer beschädigt
wie kharkiv oder hostel am stadtrand von
kiew als nächstes sei besser dran
fürchtet der ukrainische präsident
bomben auf odessa artillerie und raketen
gegen odessa das wird ein
kriegsverbrechen von historischem ausmaß
bürger russlands es ist nicht nur ein
kampf für den frieden in der ukraine
es ist auch ein kampf für irland es sind
viele mutige menschen in russland die
gegen die sogenannte sonderoperation des
kremls protestieren die polizei greift
hart durch in moskau und in anderen
städten mehr als 3500 demonstranten sind
festgenommen worden laut russischen
innenministerium
auch in der ukraine weiter proteste wie
hier in nova kafka einer kleinstadt die
früh von den russen eingenommen wurde am
tag elf des krieges wollen sie mit ihren
fahnen zeigen dass sie ukraine sind
katrin eigendorf ist weiter für uns in
der ukraine auch heute gab es auf
verschiedenen ebenen telefonate und
internationale vermittlungsversuche
katrin gibt es den ukraine hoffnung
die menschen verfolgen ja hier die
nachrichten praktisch den ganzen tag
also die hängen alle vor ihren computern
an den handys und gucken
jedes einzelne gespräch sich an aber die
hoffnung auf eine diplomatische lösung
die hoffnung dass ist irgend jemandem
gelingen könnte in der welt auf vladimir
putin einzuwirken die ist doch relativ
klein also wenn ich hier mit den
menschen sprechen alle sagen mit putin
wird dieser krieg nicht ändern es ist
die einzige chance ist putins entmachten
das würde ich mal sagen ist sie so die
durchgängige mal und die menschen sagen
was der westen jetzt tun kann ist uns
waffen liefern und das allerwichtigste
was sie immer wieder als forderung im
raum steht ist schließt endlich den
luftraum über der ukraine um weitere
luftangriffe zu verhindern das ist das
was die menschen uns hier immer wieder
mit geben und teilweise gehen sie uns
auch das ist mir gerade passiert auch
als deutsche journalisten manchmal ich
auf der straße ganz ruppig an als ob
jeder für verantwortlich wären welche
entscheidungen in berlin oder auch in
brüssel getroffen werden und wir müssen
dann klar machen das ist nicht unsere
entscheidung aber das vertrauen in
vermittlungsversuche in diplomatie ist
hier sehr sehr gering die einschätzung
von katrin eigendorf live aus meine ski
vielen dank
innerhalb der vergangenen zehn tage sind
schon mehr als 1,5 millionen menschen
vor den bomben in der ukraine geflohen
mit abstand die meisten flüchtenden hat
bislang polen aufgenommen auch in
russland der republik moldau in der
slowakei und in rumänien wird schutz
gesucht und auch ungarn hat seine
grenzen geöffnet und fast 170.000
menschen aufgenommen nicht immer mit
offenen armen wie patricia schäfer
berichtet
eine gute bewachte turnhalle in der
ungarischen kleinstadt hat eine halbe
autostunde hinter der grenze wir dürfen
nicht hinein weil hier ein
provisorisches einwanderungszentrum
eingerichtet wurde vor den toren treffen
ludmilla und ihre tochter tatjana aus
kiew der vater der familie darf das
gelände nicht verlassen
meine tochter und ich haben biometrische
pässe mein mann einen normalen
ukrainischen kann der wurde ihm von den
ungarischen grenzbeamten abgenommen und
gesagt er dürfe nicht einreisen und
müsse eine spezielle registrierung
besorgen
zuvor waren sie problemlos von der
ukraine nach moldawien und rumänien ein
reist erst an der ungarischen grenze gab
es probleme lieblich totale pässe wurden
uns abgenommen und liegen noch an der
grenze sind die jungs von drinnen wurden
uns bilder zugespielt manche sitzen hier
schon seit tagen fest darunter eltern
mit kleinen kindern und gebrechliche
alte menschen sowie der vater der
familie aus kiew der eine behinderung
hat und nach den regeln denken
eigentlich problemlos einreisen durfte
sie haben keine biometrische pass oder
die haben kinder nur mit geburtsurkunde
weil sie nicht geschafft haben ist es
krieg wie sollen sie da kommen wir wo
sollen sie hingehen wo sollen sich hier
versuchen die sind über die grenze die
sind froh dass sie in sicherheit sind
aber kommen nicht weiter die ungarische
regierung beruft sich auf europäische
regeln zur grenzsicherung nach außen
zeigt ungarn ein flüchtlings
freundliches gesicht aber da wo die
weltöffentlichkeit nicht so aufmerksam
hinschaut werden menschen die hals über
kopf aus einem kriegsgebiet fliehen
mussten aufgehalten auf eine art die
nicht sehr freundlich scheint um es mal
vorsichtig auszudrücken heute kommt
niemand mehr hier raus der bus der
freiwilligen helfer aus magdeburg muss
nun halb leer die heimreise antreten
deutschland will alle flüchtlinge aus
der ukraine aufnehmen und zwar
unabhängig von ihrer nationalität das
betont innenministerin feser offiziell
registriert sind mittlerweile knapp
38.000 menschen allein nach berlin
sollen innerhalb eines tages 11.000
gekommen seien sie angemessen zu
empfangen und unterzubringen ist nicht
nur für die hauptstadt eine
herausforderung katrin lindner berichtet
frankfurt oder einfahrt für einen
sonderzug aus polen mit ukrainischen
flüchtlingen alle müssen umsteigen
übersetzt die freiwillige helferin die
bundespolizei kontrolliert die pässe wer
einen blauen ukrainischen hat darf
sofort weiter
diese frau hat nur noch tränen ihre
mutter ihr mann sind zurückgeblieben wir
wollen dass das alles aufhört wir wollen
keinen krieg wir wollen frieden sagt sie
sie weiter check ist seit freitagmorgen
unterwegs und kommt aus der nähe von rom
an sie ist überwältigt von der hilfe auf
die sie überall getroffen ist ich muss
euch allen sagen die ukraine sind sehr
sehr dankbar
frankfurt oder ist der erste deutsche
bahnhof für viele ukraine flüchtlinge
passieren die stadt bleiben oder steigen
um freiwillige übersetzen versuche und
helfen wo sie können das wird aber auf
dauer so nicht funktionieren wir kriegen
das übers wochenende hin dank der tollen
menschen die hier unterstützen aber wir
brauchen die dann professionelle
strukturen die das gewährleisten auch
berlin hat um unterstützung gebeten der
bund will reagieren so die bundes
innenministerin in bericht aus berlin
wir haben jetzt am wochenende in der tat
dafür gesorgt und da bin ich der
bundespolizei auch sehr dankbar dass sie
sehr schnell umgeleitet hat dass wir
versucht haben den menschen auch andere
angebote zu machen nicht nur nach berlin
zu fahren sondern auch in andere große
städte in der bundesrepublik der
flüchtlingsstrom hat erst begonnen wie
viele kommen ist ungewiss
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine und
den geflüchteten mit geldspenden helfen
wollen dann können sie das tun zum
beispiel beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190 zum krieg in
der ukraine senden wir auch heute wieder
ein zdf spezial direkt nach diesen
nachrichten und jederzeit über die
aktuellen entwicklungen
informiert sind sie mit unserem live
blog in der zdf- heute- app
der krieg treibt die menschen in
deutschland weiter auf die straße wenn
auch weniger als vor einer woche die
friedensdemo vor der frankfurter
hauptwache mit etwa 4000 menschen ein
meer aus gelb und blau auch vor der
russischen botschaft in berlin haben
einige tausend demonstranten gegen
putins vorgehen demonstriert die
kreditkartenanbieter visa und mastercard
stellen ihr russlandgeschäft 1 damit
würden in russland ausgestellten karten
im ausland nicht mehr funktionieren und
karten von ausländischen banken nicht
mehr in russland heißt es von den
unternehmen russische kunden könnten
ihre karten im inland aber weiterhin
nutzen sagt die zentralbank in moskau
der krieg treibt die energiepreise zu
immer neuen höchstständen die cdu
fordert deshalb steuersenkungen
parteivize linnemann sagte im zdf
morgenmagazin die mehrwertsteuer sollte
auf 7 prozent gesenkt werden oder sogar
noch weiter die wirtschaftlichen folgen
des ukraine krieges in deutschland
müssten jetzt schnell abgefedert werden
zur corona lage da zeigt die impfquote
dass der erhoffte schub durch nova wachs
bislang ausgeblieben ist der neue
impfstoff ist seit gut einer woche zu
haben trotzdem ist weiterhin etwa jeder
vierte hier nicht geimpft dabei steigen
die infektionszahlen wieder das robert
koch institut meldet fast 116
1900 neue infektionen binnen 24 stunden
fast 9000 mehr als vor einer woche die
sieben tage incidents liegt jetzt bei
1.200
31,1
der kampf gegen antisemitismus und
rassismus steht im mittelpunkt der woche
der brüderlichkeit die wurde heute
eröffnet bei einem festakt in osnabrück
wurde die über rosenzweig medaille
verliehen an den präsidenten von
eintracht frankfurt peter fischer und
den jüdischen sportverband makabi
deutschland für ihr engagement im sport
das motto der aktionswoche zur
christlich jüdischen verständigung
lautet dieses jahr
fairplay jeder mensch zählt jeder mensch
zählt das kann gerade jetzt gar nicht
oft genug gesagt werden dieser krieg in
europa hinterlässt auch im kulturbetrieb
spuren die semperoper in dresden will
weiter mit künstlerinnen und künstlern
aus russland zusammenarbeiten und zeigt
zugleich musikalisch flagge bei der
premiere von aida gestern abend thomas
bärsch war dabei
verschwinden werden unsere feinde wie
tauben der sonne heißt es im text der
ukrainischen hymne die die semperoper
gestern abend vor der aida premiere
platzierte für das dresdner publikum
eine chance anteilnahme zu zeigen
eine premiere und gleichzeitig das zu
erleben ist schon beeindruckend und
gleichzeitig auch bett also bedrückend
einfach dass man stück bei ihnen ist in
der ukraine dass man sie denkt und nicht
vermisst an der oper mit ihrem
internationalen ensemble geht der krieg
nicht spurlos vorüber künstler aus
belarus der ukraine aber auch wussten
stehen in dresden unter vertrag und
genau das machte es in kriegszeiten
kompliziert
wir haben ja schon das problem jetzt mit
den mit dem zahlungsverkehr also seid
das licht nicht mehr gibt machen wir uns
schon gedanken wie zahlen der russischen
künstlerin und künstler die bei uns
jetzt gastieren werden ich hoffe das
wird irgendwie gehen auch der
reiseverkehr das ist ja alles moment
unglaublich schwer
bei der aufführung mit dem monumentalen
bühnenbild und der kriegs zimmerte
drängen sich parallelen zum geschehen in
der ukraine fast auf doch die
regisseurin weitet den blick
wir wollen ja auch mal eins feststellen
krieg war in den letzten jahren ständig
auf der welt es ist nur jetzt für uns
sehr nah
den abend im zeichen des krieges hat die
semperoper auch außen an ihrem gebäude
dokumentiert die oper selbst endet
übrigens mit einem wort peitsche frieden
jetzt zu den paralympics in peking
christin wieder mit einer medaillen die
fünfte bisher zweiter tag zweite
medaille für anna-lena forster erneut
silber im mono ski diesmal im super-g
allerdings hauchdünn an paralympischen
gold vorbeigeschrammt was die deutsche
fahnenträgerin etwas ärgerte
ein schrei im ziel von anna-lena forster
bereits zum zweiten mal hat er die
japanerin momo camorra opfer wie
goldmedaille weggeschnappt
in peking gibt es für die 26-jährige
mono ski fahrerin im super g das gleiche
resultat wie tags zuvor in der abfahrt
diesmal erreicht sie das ziel nach einer
minute und 23 84 sekunden nur elf
hundertstel sekunden fehlen anna-lena
forster zum paralympics-sieg silber
hinter morioka bronze gewinnt die
chinesin st
kurz vor saisonende verbuchen die
deutschen biathleten noch einmal schöne
erfolge denise herrmann wird beim
weltcup im finnischen kontiolahti in der
verfolgung dritte teamkollege erik
lesser erkämpft sogar überraschend platz
zwei
erik lesser noch einmal im mittelpunkt
seines teams kein wunder nach dieser
herausragenden leistung der mann mit der
nummer 12 er bleibt fehlerfrei am
schießstand und zeigt kämpfer qualitäten
auf der strecke am ende nur der franzose
vor erik lesser da hat einfach alles
gepasst an diesem tag mensch und
material genau wie zuvor bei ines
hermann die sprintsiegerin von gestern
leistet sich allerdings drei
schießfehler und beendet dieses
verfolgungsrennen deshalb hinter tiere
leck auf aus norwegen und dorothea
wierer aus italien auf platz drei
große freude auch bei freestyler leon
vockensperger der als erster deutscher
snowboarder einen slopestyle weltcup
gewinnt und die gesamtführung in dieser
disziplin übernimmt leon güte rundete
als dritter das starke ergebnis in
georgien ab und fußball-zweitligist
schalke 04 hat cheftrainer dimitrios
gramm muss entlassen das gestrige 13 4
gegen hansa rostock war die achte saison
niederlage für die königsblauen platz
sechs in der tabelle zu wenig für den
bundesliga-absteiger
keinerlei ruhe auf schalke dankeschön
gerne fehlt noch das wetter der montag
beginnt im südwesten sonnig später
scheint auch im norden häufig die sonne
nach osten hin ist es wolkig es bleibt
aber meist trocken die temperatur steigt
auf 2 bis 9 grad und die kommenden tage
werden sonnig und allmählich wärmer
viertel vor zehn begrüßt sie marietta
slomka im heute-journal wir wünschen
ihnen einen guten start in die neue
woche sagen tschüss bis morgen